President Biden fell yesterday not just
a little stumble not just a little
tumble a full on Fall during the Air
Force Academy graduation
[Applause]
graduates and he goes down all the way
down
not Chevy Chase doing Jerry Ford on SNL
all the way down has to be helped up by
three three men
he points back at something on the floor
which is kind of funny he turns back he
says like oh is that it was that Pebbles
fault you know but it's it's ultimately
not funny it's sad
and it's not even news
that's why I had to play it
it's not really making news but it was a
bad fall and it's not news and that's
really weird it's not news because we've
come to expect it we've come to expect
it and we've come to accept it the
president is mentally and physically
falling apart the president refuses to
campaign
for re-election he didn't even campaign
last time
for his first term for his
administration
we've reached a new stage of national
scandal
it is not just that we don't have a
functional president that our political
system is not run the way it's supposed
to be run and it's not even just that
our rulers have ceased to pretend that
the government is run the way it's
supposed to be run the most scandalous
part of all
is that we all know it we joke about it
openly on the left and on the right and
nobody seems to care I'm Michael
knowlesis the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
to the show in just a moment forget
about politics forget about this crazy
event that involved the daily wire on
Twitter last night
we have a follow-up to that Toronto Blue
Jays player who totally turned his back
on his beliefs and apologized for
criticizing pride month
that guy got a very nasty reaction from
the crowd we'll get to that in in one
moment first though
the president
can't function he can't speak he doesn't
know which end is up he can't walk and
he's not campaigning Peter Ducey one of
the few conservatives in the White House
breast pool asked the president's press
secretary about this is this guy at any
point in the campaign going to actually
hit the campaign Trail
it's been more than a month since the
re-election announcement is President
Biden going to hold a campaign event
ever
so I will say this to you Peter as you
know we follow the rule of law Here We
Believe In following the rule of law as
it relates hold on as it relates
I'm I'm about to answer your question
here uh as it relates to anything that
uh that is connected to the campaign any
rallies any events uh any any
endorsement anything that is connected
to the 2024 reelection that is not going
to certainly come from here that is
going to come from his campaign or the
DNC and or the DNC so what green
Jean-Pierre is using to evade this
question is the Hatch Act is the idea
that government workers are not allowed
to engage in explicitly campaign-related
political activity so when Peter Ducey
says hey is he going to hit the campaign
Trail she says well I'm not allowed to
talk about the campaign but that's
obviously not true because the White
House while it can't maybe talk about
the inner workings of any presidential
campaign can at least talk about whether
or not the guy is going to do it the the
White House Press Secretary can at least
talk about the president's schedule is
he thinking about making a stopover in
Iowa is he thinking about maybe
traveling to New Hampshire oh no Peter
I'm not going to answer that because the
answer is no the president right now has
no intention of seriously campaigning
and why would he he doesn't need to
campaign if he didn't need to campaign
last time he doesn't need to campaign
this time if last time Joe Biden could
hide out in his basement and
occasionally hold an event or two with
18 people and do the rest of the
campaign virtually then certainly he can
do that for reelection when his only
challenges are Marianne Williamson the
new AG lady the the hippie dippy dark
psychic forces lady that she's not going
to pose a real challenge
and Bobby Kennedy Jr who
is a Kennedy so you'd think that he
could post something of a challenge
he's a committed liberal in the 1960s
fashion but the Democrats and the
progressives have moved on from that
1960s style liberalism so he's not going
to really pose a serious challenge to
Joe Biden so why not well you might say
well he needs to start campaigning now
to build the narrative for the general
election whether it's Trump whether it's
DeSantis whether it's Chris Christie who
we all know is going to be the nominee
because the chrisons the croissants upon
us but regardless of who that is
shouldn't Joe Biden start his campaign
now no why would he what's the campaign
the campaign is we're going to maintain
the power structure exactly as it is
without accountability
and you can deal with it the campaign in
2024 is going to be we're going to
harvest ballots we're going to get our
machine going we're going to have
widespread mail-in ballots and we're
going to hope that we can squeak by
that's that even though Joe Biden has
historic levels of unpopularity even
though the country's falling apart on on
every single front he doesn't need to
campaign which is not just a knock on
Joe Biden the fact that Biden's falling
down all the time and can't speak is not
just a knock on Joe Biden it just it
describes an aspect of the political
system that is especially corrupt and
especially decayed
not only is is the government working in
a way that's not in accordance with
Schoolhouse Rock a bill up on Capitol
Hill the U.S constitutional the rest of
it
and not only
or or is the government not pretending
otherwise anymore not only is the
government transparent about that but we
all know it and we are not scandalized
by it anymore that's the biggest Scandal
of all that's that's how you know how
far gone we are and we need to talk
about it when you want to talk to your
friends you got to check out pure talk
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles a
company that I am very proud to stand
behind and a company that's proud to
stand behind us over here in our country
is pure talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce
puretalk shares our beliefs our vision
for the country that is why Pure Talk is
the official cell phone wireless
provider for the daily wire that's not
the only reason Pure Talk also happens
to be the most Dependable 5G Network in
the United States you're going to hear
that you know what you're going to hear
it's one of the it's not it's the best
this is a top tier provider at a
fraction of the cost of those other woke
companies ATT Verizon T-Mobile
companies that don't care about you or
your values are worse seek to undermine
them in fact you can get unlimited talk
text and unlimited data with a mobile
hotspot for just 55 a month I promise
you that it's cheaper than what you were
paying now for all those things you vote
with how you spend your money so stop
supporting leftist wireless companies
that don't support you go to
puretalk.com nulls you get great
coverage and save while you're doing it
go to puretalk.com Knowles you'll save
an additional fifty percent five zero
off your first month because they
actually value you puretalk.com Knowles
Pure Talk Wireless for Americans by
Americans last night
I feel like I haven't left my desk
we were here We were supposed to do a
very simple what is a woman release for
the one year anniversary of Matt's movie
It the movie was such a big success we
were going to do a one year anniversary
celebration and air it for everybody on
Twitter free for 24 hours not just for
the members but for everybody
to celebrate the movie to celebrate Elon
musk's takeover of Twitter to celebrate
that one of the big Tech platforms is
now going to endorse Free Speech okay
great and then we're working with
Twitter on all of this and then we're
told by the trust and safety team no
sorry actually we're gonna not only not
work with you on this event we're going
to suppress the movie if you put it up
onto Twitter
is it what what happened to free speech
what happened to the big conservatives
having a voice now on what about that
that was gone okay so we were a little
confused we said we're going to go ahead
with our event if Twitter wants to
suppress it okay elon's sending us mixed
messages here we I don't really
understand what's going on here but okay
whatever we air it and it is suppressed
and then Elon starts responding
and then we get a report that the head
of the trust and safety team over at
Twitter
resigns or is fired but but we're still
being suppressed and we just we just
don't know what on Earth is going on
Elon starts responding to us personally
responds to a tweet that I posted a
tweet kind of throwing a little bit of
subtle shade at Twitter Elon liked that
tweet he was responding to Jordan
Peterson Jordan was here last night he's
responding to the Daily wire but it was
still unclear what exactly is going on
then this morning
this morning Elon Musk tweets out the
movie and he says every parent should
watch this movie
and when we we said well hold on what is
this Elon had a great response Elon said
the controversy will drive views
and Jordan responds to him and says you
are a complicated person which is very
very true because we didn't know at the
moment
is this
Elon got out foxed or Elon didn't know
about this
is this Elon did know about this and
he's a hypocrite about free speech is
this Elon playing 4D chess and
generating some kind of controversy and
having an excuse now to can part of his
liberal apparatic trust and safety team
what is going
on it's still unclear to me though the
result has been wonderful and so great
on Elon great on Twitter to get this
message out to say on Twitter right now
not only can you say that a man is a man
and a woman is a woman but you can
expose the gender ideology for what it
is
not only does this vindicate the
purchase of Twitter don't forget Ron
DeSantis launched his presidential
campaign on Twitter in Twitter spaces
some days ago
Rhonda Sanders's campaign is running
against wokeness and then all of a
sudden Twitter comes out and says you're
not allowed to say that a man is a man
and a woman is a woman the specific
reason they told us that they were going
to suppress our video was two specific
instances of misgendering in the movie
that is calling a girl a girl and a boy
a boy in one case a father who referred
to his daughter as she and he's in jail
for that in Canada
foreign
we don't know exactly what what did it
but all's well that ends well this was a
great ending and you've got to also
remember what kind of a tough position
Elon Musk is in this is the point I've
been making since the beginning
Elon Musk is not just fighting against
some woke employees Twitter
Elon Musk is fighting against an entire
not only National system but
International System of censorship Elon
Musk is fighting against garm that
censorship Wing that has now been
incorporated into the world economic
form an industry-wide multinational
program to enforce transgenderism and
radical environmentalism and all the
rest of the the leftist ideology Elon
Musk is fighting against the advertisers
Elon Musk is fighting against the market
Elon Musk is fighting against major
asset managers he's fighting against a
whole system here
Twitter today is worth one third of what
it was worth when Elon Musk bought it
Elon Musk paid 44 billion dollars for
Twitter it's worth one third of that
today Twitter was already before he
bought it on a path of almost inevitable
bankruptcy so the guy is under a lot
of pressure
and if he can
finagle his way to keep Twitter as a
free speech platform or forget about
free speech I don't even care all that
much about totally free speech what I
care about is the ability to tell the
truth
which are those are different things
it's good to have free speech okay but
none of us actually supports total Free
Speech this is the point of my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds everybody hello thank you that was
that was actually pretty quick today
every society has taboos and standards
and Norms what we want the very least
though is the freedom to tell the truth
which was previously suppressed now
now available on Twitter speaking of top
Executives and speaking of Ron DeSantis
by the way who launched his campaign on
Twitter Ron DeSantis
is not doing great right now
he's not doing great against Donald
Trump according to
the latest poll numbers desantis's
announcement did not close the gap
between him and Trump trump still has a
34 point lead in the race
Trump's lead is down a little bit from a
43-point lead
but that constriction of the poll
numbers appears to have happened before
Ron DeSantis Ron DeSantis is
presidential announcement
so
I think DeSantis is a great Governor I
think he's got a very strong message I
think he's obviously an extremely
intelligent competent guy he's one of
the most conservative presidential
candidates we've seen in my lifetime I'm
not disparaging him I'm just describing
a fact his announcement didn't work it
hasn't moved the needle the Delta
between him and Trump is just still so
massive
there's just some intangible ineffable
je ne sais quoi about the the Trump
campaign that the DeSantis campaign has
not yet figured out how to crack despite
really targeted attacks Trump handing
the country over to fauci really
targeted attacks on some of Trump's
picks and decisions throughout his
administration
still hasn't quite done it
Trump just gave
a response on the campaign trail that I
think helps to get it why
Trump seems Untouchable why he's the
Teflon Don Trump was asked about
wokeness you know wokeness that's that
word on the right we're all just beating
the hell out of wokeness we hate
wokeness and and that's persuading a lot
of moderates and people in the middle
wokeness has got to end here's Trump's
answer on wokeness
it's gone sick and I don't like the term
well because I hear woke woke woke you
know it's like just a term that used
half the people can't even Define it
they don't know what it is
as is often the case well everybody is
zigging Donald Trump is zagging the guy
is contrarian not just with the broader
culture he's contrarian even with the
right the conservative movement the
Republican party in part we should
expect this because the guy didn't spend
his life in the conservative movement of
the Republican Party
and so on this one this is the easiest
softball oh yeah wokeness bad he says I
don't like that term it's kind of a
silly term no one can really Define it
and you know what
he's kind of right
he's kind of right we we use the term as
a shorthand to refer to the extreme
leftists
but a lot of people who regularly use
that term
can't really Define it
you'll notice on my show
I tend and did my writing and in my
speeches I tend to refer to the libs
I don't refer to the wokies the
wokesters the leftists exclusively
mostly I refer to the libs because
there's a big debate on the right
between is wokism
a betrayal of liberalism or is wokism
The Logical conclusion of liberalism
and not just modern Progressive
liberalism there's another big debate on
the right which is is modern Progressive
leftism
a betrayal of liberalism an illiberal
kind of liberalism or
is modern Progressive leftism The
Logical conclusion of liberalism
in the more libertarian types the more
classical liberal identifying types they
say the former and the conservatives and
that traditionalists
in the old school right-wingers we say
it's the latter
we say this wokism stuff this was always
going to be the consequence of
liberalism just look at transgenderism
you have the the classical liberals who
say transgenderism it's a betrayal not
only of liberalism but but even of the
gay rights movement it's a betrayal of
all it's a betrayal of feminism but the
conservatives we say
no it's The Logical conclusion of it
because if men and women are pretty much
the same then you're going to get
transgenderism feminism says men and
women are basically the same and so you
get the gay rights movement the gay
rights movement then gives you the
redefinition of marriage redefinition of
marriage then gets you
transgenderism because all of it says
that men and women are pretty much
interchangeable
that's a consequence of liberalism this
flattening liberalism which says that
we're not born into particular roles and
duties some of which are unchosen many
of which are unchosen we have an
obligation to them regardless in a
certain circumstances into communities
that we didn't choose but we have an
obligation to them anyway that's that's
what the conservatives believe the
Liberals just focus on that hyper
individualism you can do whatever you
want just don't hurt anybody or scare
the horses okay well
that's what the Liberals say but that
liberalism is going to inevitably lead
you to wokism and what Trump is saying
here
is he that term I don't know you just
want to avoid it you just want to avoid
talking about how liberalism is bad but
I'm not going to and so what does Trump
say he says it's not just that the crazy
Tran stuff is bad
it's that free trade can be bad it's not
just that the crazy trans stuff is bad
it's that the free movement of peoples
across borders can be very bad
it's not just that the trans stuff is
really bad it's that the upending of all
of our Traditions many of which can't be
written down on a napkin in some
rationalist Treatise the upending of our
saluting the flag and having hot dogs on
the fourth of July and just doing things
the way we used to do them because of
sheer tradition and Prejudice Prejudice
in the good sense of that word we just
kind of do it out of a pre-judgment out
of a gut instinct
that that rationalism is bad too
Trump is expressing
a deeply conservative impulse that is
frankly much more in line with what
conservatism
has meant going back to the French
Revolution going back to Edmund Burke up
through much of the American old Riot
before it was taken over by the libs I
think that is part of that junase I
think that is why a lot of other
candidates even very impressive
candidates like Ron DeSantis haven't
quite caught up with him
yet
okay what whatever you want to say about
Trump the guy his campaign is still on
fire and when you want to set things on
fire you've got to check out Grill
Blazer right now go to grillblazer.com
are you tired of waiting ages for your
grill to heat up well now you can say
goodbye to those tedious moments of
impatiently watching the charcoal burn
and say hello to instant barbecue
Perfection thanks to our new friends
over at Grill Blazer Grill Blazers Grill
guns are designed to do everything from
expertly searing your Meats to lighting
charcoal grills wood stoves outdoor
fireplaces and just about anything you
can think of
that you would need a high power fire
source to solve that problem
[Music]
anything Grill Blazers offers two types
of Grill guns the grill gun basic is a
high power propane torch designed to
Light charcoal and wood grills and
smokers burns up to 3 600 Degrees 30
inch flame for anything you need a big
bed torch to do and the SUV gun has a
shorter Barrel perfect for professional
Culinary Kitchen uses from gently
carbonizing brulay or other sugars and
fruits to rapidly searing steaks outside
on the grill use the grill gun may
result in extreme Grill Envy from your
neighbors and increased demands for
barbecue parties get your grill gun from
Grill Blazers today let the grilling
Adventures begin grillblazer.com Knowles
promo code nulls for 15 off your order
rollblazer.com Knowles promo code nulls
for 15 off
yes or no is not just a game it's the
internet's favorite interview Show
everybody's talking about it they've
done polls it's also still a game and
you can pre-order yours now at
dailywire.com shop there is a rumor
perhaps a conspiracy theory that the
pre-order is ending soon they are
selling like a wildfire so if you want
to get it you really ought to get it now
we've sold out every single time
thousands and thousands of copies this
one is selling out extremely fast so
make sure you get yours don't miss your
chance to cause controversy and reveal
the true positions of your friends and
family when it comes to the most hotly
debated and titillating topics of our
time speaking of hotness
we did an episode who wrote this copy
someone who's got a crush on Lauren
Southern that wrote this copy though
she's a very beautiful lady we did an
episode with my friend Lauren Southern
here's a quick teaser a gay duck
[Music]
M to be
in the United Arab
[Music]
IC
[Applause]
there is more in the works for yes or no
coming soon so seize the opportunity
while you can go to dailywire.com shop
today my favorite comment yesterday from
slap my base 3825 who says if the
corporations actually believed in the
gay ideology I dare them to advocate for
it in their Middle East divisions or in
China it's a good observation because
it's only the Western
iterations of the brands that put on the
rainbow in June the ones in Saudi Arabia
don't don't change their logos to be
rainbows or in China or elsewhere but I
don't want this to make people
complacent
is the the argument
or the the point of that argument is
that this Pride stuff doesn't really
change the culture it's just a kind of a
rainbow facade on the same old system
that doesn't really change but that
isn't quite true
yes the corporations themselves are not
going in and changing their their logos
during this month in those countries
but the West broadly is
the United States the state department
the ngos all of these non-governmental
busybody organizations Imperial
organizations from the West do go into
these countries and they will often tie
Aid dollars they will often tie all
sorts of support in Military Support
even to
liberalizing policies
especially policies regarding sex and
gender and this radical sexual
Revolution ideology so that does happen
it's just not the conservatives who are
the corporations rather who are at the
Vanguard of that is often the state
department and the ngos but the
corporations do follow make no mistake
the West is pushing the rainbow in many
ways the rainbow has become the Imperial
flag of the West just as The
Star-Spangled Banner is the national
flag of the United States so too the
pride flag The Pride progress flag
increasingly is the Imperial flag of the
liberal West
now
speaking of the presidential candidates
we've got a new candidate in the race
not officially yet but we've had the
official announcement of the impending
official announcement which candidate is
it I'm not talking about Chris Christie
I'm not talking about the criticians
that hasn't happened yet I'm talking
about
Mike Pence
Mike Pence according to reports will
announce his run at a rally style event
in Des Moines Iowa next Wednesday
according to sources familiar with
Pence's plans
a lot of people don't think that Mike
Pence has a chance in this race looking
at the poll numbers a lot of people
might say oh Mike Pence is a really nice
guy but but the numbers just aren't
aren't there for him what is Mike
Pence's Lane Mike Pence does have a lane
it's it's narrow it probably is not
going to be successful but in a
presidential race anything can happen
especially when you consider that they
might throw Trump in prison
there are at least three locales that
are trying to put Trump in prison right
now probably more to come
Rhonda santis is very well tested very
impressive at the state level but he's
not totally tested at the national stage
Anything Could Happen everyone thought
Jeb Bush was going to be the nominee in
2016. uh Jeb obviously did not become
the nominee so DeSantis could Jeb out
who knows and then we're in a whole new
ball game what is Pence's Lane
his Lane is Iowa he's got to hit Iowa
really really hard
he's got to win over the Evangelical
base
in some ways this was the cruise
campaign strategy in in 2016. go hard
after Iowa go hard after the Evangelical
base which worked Cruz did win Iowa was
the number two guy in 2016.
Pence could do that and then Pence has
something else that that helps him out
here which is that Pence is acceptable
to the business wing of the GOP
Ence is acceptable to the Chamber of
Commerce when weighing of the GOP Pence
is not going to go hard after
corporations Pence is not going to
Advocate hard for protective tariffs or
anything like that
so that's a real Advantage it's
it's an older model of running for
president on the right
it was a model that was powerful in the
1990s in the early 2000s it's kind of
waned in recent years
but it was a model that worked for a
long time and right now no other
candidate in the race can really do that
Tim Scott
maybe to some degree
[Music]
Nikki Haley I'm not so sure I think
she's a little bit more ambiguous on
that I don't think Nikki Haley is going
to going to play very well in Iowa
the vague obviously is not going to be
running on an Evangelical Christian
campaign
Chris Chris Christie's not going to be
running on an Iowa
Evangelical operation campaign so there
is it's not totally
crazy I wouldn't put my money on Pence
becoming the nominee to put it mildly
but but there is a lane there is a kind
of a logic to it it just requires the
GOP to kind of
fling back like a like a rubber band
stretch too far in One Direction would
have to fling back to a a tried and true
strategy speaking of traditional views
the Dodgers the LA Dodgers who invited
this satanic drag troop the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence who mock not only
Catholic nuns but mock Christ and the
crucifixion and are just not doing good
stuff uh invited them to be honored for
a pride month at Dodger Stadium and then
there was backlash so they disinvited
them then there was backlash to the
backlash so they reinvited them and now
they're going to hold
a Christian Faith and Family Day in July
I think they already were hosting that
but they're promoting this now okay
not good enough even Bishop Barron who's
a very nice is Catholic bishop very nice
guy uh he's not really a bomb thrower or
anything he points out he says this is
just not enough uh
you know we cannot accept the LA Dodgers
for doing this we've got to keep the
pressure up
we should boycott the LA Dodgers we
should protest the LA Dodgers we should
put the LA Dodgers on the transheiser
bush Target Cole's list this is
completely unacceptable stuff
and I know that there are going to be
people speaking of that old style
Republican politics sort of thing uh who
are going to be people who say well look
can't we just meet in the middle
somewhere or can't we we don't we can't
boycott every company can't we just all
right they're going to have the look
they're going to have the satanic parody
of the mass uh devil worshiping drag
queens day but they're also going to
have a day where they
acknowledge the existence of Christians
so look isn't that kind of a win no no
you can't please at everybody that's
always the case but you especially can't
please everybody during periods of
intense division
so when we broadly agree on things it's
easier to please more people more of the
time when we can't agree on anything
when we can't agree on what a woman is
when we can't agree on anthropology when
it can't agree on epistemology only
can't agree on what good and bad is when
we can't agree on what the role of the
state in good and bad is when we can't
agree on language the meaning of
language then you really can't please
everybody all of the time that then
you're you're to be politically
successful
you're probably only going to please a
minority of people when you live in
Revolutionary times which the left has
voiced Upon Us time and time again but
but especially now when you live in
Revolutionary times then the way you're
going to make political change is is to
appeal to a minority of people
at at all times it is it is a minority
of people who make revolutionary change
think of the Bolsheviks who dishonestly
presented themselves as a majority they
were distinct minority of people
look at what's going on the baseball
audience is broadly conservative the
people who run baseball are
extraordinarily left-wing and they're
they're cow Towing to left Wingers well
look what happened Anthony Bass the
Toronto Blue Jay he comes out he
criticizes pride month then there's
backlash from his bosses presumably so
he throws his integrity under the bus he
makes an apology for attacking pride
month and then he trots out there onto
the field listen to how the Blue Jays
fans greeted him
business
you can hear one boo in particular
and then
he trots out there
has a little conversation in Shallow
left field
okay it's still it's sometimes a little
hard to make out what the audience is
saying here
but then it becomes a little clearer
is he's trotting from shallow left field
out to the pitcher's mound you hear the
booze
why was he booed
he was booed because now nobody supports
him
the pro
Pride people obviously don't support him
he he posted to his Instagram a very
clear directed video about how he thinks
pride is evil
the conservatives don't like it the
normal people don't like him because he
then threw his integrity under the bus
said oh I'm sorry I offended I never
wanted to offend anybody you know I'm
sorry the pride Community I support them
blah blah blah okay so now he's got
nobody I'm reminded in Dante's Divine
Comedy right right at the very beginning
of Hell or the people who were lukewarm
and they're there it's not the deepest
part of hell it's not the hottest part
of hell it's it's in some ways though
even
more ignominious because it's it's the
people who are obviously unacceptable to
Heaven because they have no conviction
they have no Integrity they have no
faith but they're also repulsive to the
people in hell
even hell won't accept these people
they're just to be spit out they're just
so lukewarm
don't do that there is nothing ever to
be gained by apologizing to an unjust
mob there's one time I was on Fox News
and I uh
I was I was asked about environmentalism
on the left and I said it was unjust
that the libs are exploiting a mentally
ill Swedish child to promote their
totally incoherent agenda and the host
of that program Harris Wagner didn't she
didn't bat an eyelash this is obviously
a true statement the Democrat who was on
the panel uh Chris Hahn he made a big
deal about this and yelled and screamed
but still the viewers weren't upset it
was obviously true that you know when it
came to the case of this gal Greta
thundberg her mother actually wrote a
book about how this girl had all these
sorts of mental problems and yet she was
still being exploited as the face of the
left so that we couldn't criticize their
climate policies so I just said this on
air and then some of the liberal
Executives at Fox made a big deal about
this and yelled and screamed and all the
rest of it and there was a big push
there were some emissaries from Fox News
who implored me to apologize to the
company publicly
and they said oh you'd be back you'll be
back on air in two seconds if you just
apologize I said well I don't think I
did anything wrong if I felt I did
something wrong I'd consider apologizing
but I don't think I did I think that and
that was one of the early cases where
the conservative audience
had a backlash against Fox News for
something it did that they felt was
liberal and dishonest
I said I'm not going to do that
no maybe it would have gotten me on Fox
News probably it wouldn't happen I mean
look at what just happened to Tucker
Carlson and I also went back on Fox News
relatively quickly after that anyway so
it wasn't
the devil always does this to you the
devil always gives you these sort of
Temptations and says hey if you just
throw away your integrity hey if you
just throw away your beliefs if you just
throw away your faith I'll reward you
seriously pinky swear promise and then
what happens when you make that kind of
a fasting bargain you get nothing
Anthony bass learned that the rest of
the normal people should learn that too
yesterday it was a great battle for
standards and speech normality on social
media today we're seeing the fruit of
that fight not only are the restrictions
removed but Elon personally recommended
what is a woman to his 140 million
followers saying every parent should
watch this movie why Would we give away
one of our most successful movies of all
time
biggest freedom of speech and the right
to be heard on these issues really
really matters so now we need your
support the fight is not free we have
more films to make more battles to win
join us now an annual subscription to
the Daily wire is what enables us to
make movies like what is a woman and we
have a lot more in the works so go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code woman
for 25 off your daily wire membership
and now finally finally we arrive at my
favorite time of the week when I get to
hear from you in the mailbox mailbag
sponsored by puretalk at puretalk.com
say 50 5-0 off your first month take it
away
hello Mr Knowles it is everybody's
former favorite resident bass player
slap my base and I'm coming to you with
a question over the past couple weeks
I've gone through a series of very
life-altering events with my cousin
getting married and me just turning 30
years old and I look back on my life and
I come to realize that I've not really
accomplished anything in terms of
socially and I would like to settle down
and marry a woman now more than ever
but I've yet to have any dating
experience with them at all looking
around at the options that I have right
now and it almost seems like that ninety
percent of the women that I interact
with are either huge Libs or men
pretending to be women so my question is
is it really worth looking to date when
I am extremely desperate
or at what point should I say no I
should not settle and continue to look
for the right person especially since I
have not yet dated anybody and I'm
thinking the only option I have is to
settle thanks
there's your problem right there at the
end slap there is your problem
I was with you I was trying to work out
a complex solution to your problem
until you got there to the end you said
especially when I haven't dated yet
go on a date
no but but Michael you don't understand
in the abstract at a distance in theory
these women they're probably not going
to work out
okay how do you know that
you haven't gone on a date
well I don't know I just sort of my view
of them in my mind is they probably
probably wouldn't be a good date okay
well what's the worst that happens
you go out to a restaurant you spend 40
bucks on drinks and you figure out that
the lady is a huge lib and you don't
like her and you're not going to marry
her or maybe you find out that she's a
man and that would be hopefully you'd
figure that out before you go on the
date
okay all right you're down a couple of
drinks okay you're down a few appetizers
okay and then you just go on a date
tomorrow you want to marry a woman
you're not going to marry a woman
you're going to marry a particular woman
we want to live a flourishing life
you're not going to live a flourishing
life in the abstract you're going to
live a particular life that is going to
be flourishing or not
in in its specificity in its details and
its particularity so you got to just go
out there and do it you said 90 of the
women I meet they're they're not going
to be good wives probably okay what
about the 10 10 a lot of people
have you gone out with them
Andrew Clavin gave me good advice I
repeat it in lots of Realms of life God
can't drive a parked car you're not
going to marry a woman
by sitting around thinking about the
kind of woman you might like to marry
you're going to marry a woman after
you've been dating for some time or your
married woman after you're engaged for
some time you're going to get engaged
after you propose you're going to
propose after you've dated for some time
and you're going to date for some time
after you go on a date and ask a woman
out that's what you got to do first
and maybe you're gonna waste a few
nights having drinks with girls who were
just awful okay you'll get some funny
stories out of it and then ultimately
you get a wife okay next question
hey Michael so a purely hypothetical
scenario
say someone is working for their dream
company to work for
but their company has been making some
public stances that go directly against
their beliefs
for example blue haired bleeding heart
liberal is working for a company that
has been outspoken about being
pro-second Amendment and pro-life
or on the other hand a very conservative
very Christian person works for a
company
that has made very public stances that
are pro-abortion and anti-religion
where would you draw the line how do you
feel about that compromise do you feel
like we should get out while the kittens
good or do you think we should just
stick it out and over the best
thank you
doesn't sound like your dream company
does it
if if the company that you say it's your
dream company
if they do things that are a nightmare
then it's not your dream company is it
you might say well look it's a dream
company they do great work but they've
fallen into some of the Dei stuff
because of public pressure and whatever
ESG or whatever outside forces are
forcing them to in some way participate
I don't know maybe during covert they
made you wear a mask or something you
say okay I'm going to stick it out
because that's annoying but the company
is still doing great work okay maybe
there's an argument to be made there but
if the company
is in its public stances supporting
abortion or supporting transiting the
kids or whatever any of this craziness
if the company in its public role is
making the country worse and it's not a
dream company very often people it's
kind of like what slap was just saying
with his dream girl
they construct this this dream this
dream that's just in their minds and
then the reality doesn't correspond with
that dream okay you got to choose the
reality you've got to recognize that our
imaginations are deceived you know the
real origin of pride month
is from the real origin of the rainbow
and the rainbow is a sign that God gives
to Noah After the flood and it's a
promise that he'll never again destroy
the world in a flood but what does he
say right before he gives Noah this sign
he says that God smelled a sweet Savor
and this was from Noah one of the first
things he does he gets out of the Ark
what's he do he sacrifices an animal and
burns it up to God as a sacrifice and
God smells the sweet saver and he says
he he decides that he would never again
destroy the world in a flood because the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
his youth
our imagination can very often deceive
us so yeah the company is not what you
thought it was okay
if it's really egregious if it crosses
your threshold I guess it's time to look
for a new company
or maybe there isn't a company that that
is any better and so you got to work to
improve the company from within that's
reality next question
hi Michael my name is Matthias I have a
technology question for you recently the
FDA approved Elon musk's neurolink
technology to begin conducting studies
using brain implants in humans according
to the company this
technology could potentially cure
incurable diseases such as paralysis
blindness even help people walk again
after a stroke or neurological damage
what are your thoughts on this new
technology and should we use it thanks
love the show
I'm technology skeptical as you know I'm
not I'm not into technology I don't buy
the latest screens and doodads I don't
really care about any of that
but I'm not totally opposed to
technology technology will develop and
that's fine we use technology all the
time
I'm not even opposed to plugging
something into your head I think
Cochlear implants are a great advance in
technology that help deaf people with
certain kinds of deafness be able to
hear again Rush Limbaugh had a cochlear
implant okay that's great
I'm a little skeptical of being plugged
into the Matrix I think that would be a
bad thing I'm a little skeptical of
devices that could compromise your free
will
which
some versions of putting a chip into
your brain could do some versions of
translating thoughts sort of pre-verbal
thoughts into actions could do so I'm
I'm skeptical of that but I'm not not
opposed to the technology in Principle
as always in these kinds of cases the
devil is in the details
so I would if this were a way to correct
a problem to treat an illness I would be
cautiously
hopeful about the technology If This
Were a way to improve upon Humanity to
create a new kind of human that's bigger
better faster stronger in every way
that's not fixing a deficiency but
making something new and supposedly
better I would oppose that because we we
must oppose Science and Technology
establishing dominion over the origin
and Destiny of human life
I know that's not a sexy answer that's
not a totally satisfying answer like I'm
Pro neural link or anti-neural link I'm
also very Pro Elon right now that he's
supporting the right side in speech and
in the gender ideology
um
but that's the nuanced answer we
someone's going to do this sort of stuff
we are going to explore these things
curiosity is not a virtue but it is a
fact of human life and so we've got to
make sure that we're doing it in the
right way with the right safeguards and
if it is not able to separate the bad
things from the good things then we got
to stop it next question
hey Michael my question today is about
the Holy Spirit I know the Bible tells
us that the holy spirit is a comforter
and I was just wondering if you've ever
felt comforted or convicted and you felt
like it was coming from the Holy Spirit
I hear people talking about
um
communication with God or God's calling
for their life and I just wonder if
you've experienced that in a in a way
where you feel like God is talking
directly to you thanks again for the
show
oh yeah certainly absolutely and
sometimes this is even physical and
tangible you know one can have a feeling
of this sort of thing and often though
it's semiotic the Christian view of the
world is a deeply symbolic view it's
especially true for the Catholic view of
the world there are no Miracle
incidences for the Christian you know
it's an evil generation that seeks for
signs and wonders but it's as my priest
in New York pointed out a stupid
generation that ignores signs and
wonders and so uh even you know you see
in the the story of Jesus visiting Mary
and Martha
Martha is a representative of the act of
life she's going around making the lunch
Mary is an example of the contemplative
life she's sitting at the feet of her
Lord listening to Christ and Martha
complains about this and Jesus says
uh Martha you don't understand
your sister has the better part
the act of life is important the
contemplative life is important the
contemplative life is better we're
called not primarily to that we're
called to act but we're not called
primarily to act we're called primarily
to interpret
and so we see these signs and everywhere
what do we do with that I'm I'm not the
sort of person who you know is trying to
read the tea leaves and discern exactly
what I'm supposed to do from this little
sign or that little sign
it's more important what what the Holy
Spirit
does primarily as far as I'm concerned
is to show us his presence
so what when someone sees a sign or a
wonder they say what am I to make of
this sign you say oh
yeah he's there
it makes sense
there's Providence you're in the right
place
that's it that's what I did the world is
intelligible there's a Divine logic to
the universe okay using my poultry
heaping of logic I'm going to try to
figure out the fake headlines for fake
headline Friday the rest of show
continues now do not miss it use code
Knowles at checkout dailywire.com for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign